and put your hands together for team 14.
all right
summer school sucks
let's be honest so i'm a kid i failed my
math class i'm going to go in for a
couple of months and do the same
lectures i just did in the same uh
stodgy old classroom i just sat in all
year this is we can do better than that
so
let's enter the lens classroom and so
this is a classroom that is designed to
enable individualized curriculum through
the lens of
educational gaming so
let's talk about this for a second i
want you to close your eyes
and i want you to think step one
chuck all the chairs out the window burn
the desks let's clear out the physical
space
step two
let's put in some new stuff but keep it
more open let's put in some whiteboards
let's put in some tv consoles and some
gaming consoles and let's start to think
about what this looks like let's take an
example of a math class
the kids
are all working on their own topics some
are doing common denominators some are
multiplying fractions and we are all
working on different things and
the
your your teacher is getting constant
formative assessment data from the input
of the game
and they're walking around with this
tablet and instead of being behind the
desk they are walking up to individual
students who they're seeing oh man
common denominators isn't going so hot
for jimmy so you go over and you do what
you want to do as a teacher
one-on-one tutorial work
and the students are engaged and they're
excited because this is nothing like the
classroom that they're used to it's loud
it's exciting it's interactive it's
great and so this is not just for math
we use this as a really great example
but we hope to be able to grow beyond
that into other subjects and into other
phases of active learning that this type
of classroom environment would enable
so you just describe a
sort of
edutopia but how do you get there
so i guess the main point is how to
combine experience of have a clean
environment in the class with a gaming
so a platform located with that in which
you can provide really
real tasks to the students and using
math to accomplish something really real
so how we can make the experience of the
summer be something different they
already had in the previous year so
that's the combination experience plus
the content and i think we saw summer
school as this opportunity to try
something new try something flexible try
using within the space of the classrooms
that exist but removing what's there and
trying to reimagine what that space can
be
so it's like summer school in an arcade
in a way
yeah right yeah
and how to infuse what's in these games
we love games right so what's in these
games and how can we infuse academic
content in those games and that's kind
of where we need to go next is
developing games that has the kind of
academic language academic literacy and
academic content that um you know that
will that kids will be exposed to
through what they're already being
engaged and motivated to do at home so
now you know they're doing it in a
newspaper is there a mechanism
to stay out of the fringe and enter the
center and take on because you know we
can create a million alternative
programs so here you have this idea
going to test in the the summer school
pretty safe for districts
how do you push against the center
how do you go
where is it intentionally there like
this is
specifically to help bring people i
think i think if a model works people
are going to be excited by it and if
you're using gaming if you get if you
access that private gaming um developing
world that has a ton of money schools
and administrators are probably going to
be
are they going to be excited to send the
kids to video games and the kids like it
and the kids are learning well and the
kids are doing better on tests i think
the parents are going to like it too
you